visitez un domaine viticole dans les i
mean sera désormais possible la bouche
du roi premier professionnel de la
plaine de versailles va inaugurer des
circuits oenologique à partir du 26 juin
le site implanté depuis 2010 est dans le
département proposera quatre à cinq
créneaux par semaine
c'était très important pour nous de
parler notre projet est d'allier le
tourisme est de pouvoir expliquer notre
travail
deux heures d'immersion on vous amène
dans les vignes en partant du village
plus on finit par une dégustation au
centre du vignoble avant de vous ramener
qui qui vous permettront au bout de deux
heures d'être rentré dans l'histoire de
la bouche du roi qui est très riche dans
la plaine de versailles et de connaître
vraiment tout sur nova les visiteurs
pourront notamment découvrir les six
cépages du domaine répartis sur 23
hectares
les guides présenteront également
l'histoire du sol argilo calcaires et
les dernières plantations du mois de
juin sur le site
ce circuit sur cette commune de 340
habitants est apprécié des élus locaux
je trouve que ça va amener un peu du
qualitatif au village et notamment un
peu de ça peut faire connaître un peu ce
village qui est un beau village des
yvelines et ça va montrer combien ce
département c'est s'ancrer dans l'âtre
dans la tradition on est un vieux
département à l'école mais aussi dans la
modernité dans l'avenir ces découvertes
coûtera 39 euros les responsables
espèrent attirer cet été entre 50 et 60
personnes par semaine sur ce domaine qui
devrait produire plus de cent cinquante
mille bouteilles dès 2024